- Hey legal eagles, one of the questions
I get most from college students is,
"What is the best
undergrad degree or major
"to prepare you for law school?"
Well today I'm gonna talk
about the various pros and cons
of different degrees and
by the end of this video
you will know what is
the right major for you.
So stick around.
(upbeat music)
The thing about law
school is that it takes
a lot of different skills
working in conjunction with each other.
First and foremost, you
have to be a great writer.
Second, you have to be
good at researching.
You have to be good at logical thinking.
You have to be able to
make good policy arguments
stemming from philosophy and government.
You have to be good at
historical precedent.
You have to be a good orator.
All of these things need
to work in conjunction
if you're going to get
the most out of law school
and you have to use all
of these skills together
in order to be a successful law student.
To get good grades.
And as a result there is no one major
that prepares you for law school.
Law school is unlike anything else.
In undergrad, in high school,
there is just simply nothing like it.
And there is no one major
that really prepares you
for what law school is like.
Final exams in law school are based on
what's called an issue
spotter hypothetical
where you're required
to think like a lawyer.
No undergrad major prepares
you for thinking like a lawyer.
In fact, law school
doesn't even prepare you
for thinking like a lawyer either.
That's why we created a masterclass
to actually teach students
how to think like a lawyer.
And classes in law school are taught
using the Socratic method
which is also completely different
from almost any seminar
or lecture that you've had
in college or in high school.
Professors pepper their
students with questions
to reveal the right answer.
Much in the same way that it's said
that Socrates peppered his disciples,
Plato and Aristotle with questions
to let them find the right answer.
But this methodology, it's totally unlike
anything that you'll see in college.
Especially where you have large classes
of hundreds of people or more
where there just simply isn't the ability
to go back and forth between
any particular student.
And the subject matter in law school
is also totally different
from any undergrad subject.
No one will teach you
the law that you need
before you get to law school.
Sure, you might take a business law class
or an accounting law class
but that is such a small, tiny percentage
of what you're going
to cover in law school
that there's no way for
any particular major
to really lay the foundation
of what you will need
to know in law school.
So the question is this.
If no major really
prepares you for law school
and no major can prepare
you for law school,
what major should you
sign up for in college
to best prepare you for law school?
Well the answer that
I always give is this.
You should sign up for the major
that you are most interested in.
Get a degree in a subject
that you find fascinating.
Law schools don't care about your major.
When you apply to law school,
no law school is gonna look at
which particular major you had.
But they do care about what
grades you got in college
or in undergrad.
So if you major in something
that you're really interested in
you are much more likely
to put more effort into it
and to do well in college.
And that will translate
into better grades.
Not to mention you will have
spent four to five years
studying something that you really enjoy
because you're never going
to get that time back.
Odds are you're probably
going to enjoy law school less
than your time in college.
So you might as well enjoy the most
out of your college experience.
So sign up for a major, get a degree
in something that you find fascinating
and you're willing to
study for four years.
Then when you show up for
your first day of law school
you'll be in basically the
same boat as everybody else.
You'll be starting from zero.
Because no one's major or
degree actually prepared them
for law school.
So it's okay that you're
starting from the same point
as everybody else.
So what is the best major for you?
Well, that depends.
It depends on your personal preferences.
What do you enjoy studying?
What are you fascinated by?
What can you see yourself
studying for four to five years?
And what can you reasonably do
to get good grades in
that particular major?
So unfortunately, I can't
give you one particular answer
that works for everybody.
There is no one major that
works for all law schools
and even pre-law majors
don't really prepare you
for law school.
For those of you who are unsatisfied
with an it depends answer,
well I'm sorry to say
that you're gonna have to get used to it
because if you're going to become a lawyer
you're going to hear it depends a lot.
If you ask a lawyer anything,
nine times out of 10 you'll
get the answer that it depends.
So let me know.
What major did you sign up for?
What are you going to study in college
and what have you been studying?
Do you feel like it was
a good use of your time
for four years?
If you want even more
strategies and tactics
before you get to law school,
download our free ultimate
pre-law checklist.
It's our free gift to you.
The link to that is down below
and it will give you a head start
before you get to law school.
Also please click on the
like and subscribe buttons.
The more people that
subscribe to this channel,
the more videos we'll make
on how to crush law school.
And until next time, at Legal Eagle.
Think like a lawyer and ace the exam.
So the thing about law school
is that it takes a whole.
There.
In Socratic method.
Aristotle and Plato.
Well the answer that I always give people,
let me try that again.